you know i think the biggest thing that
like is like a wall that a lot of
rappers will hit that they maybe don't
necessarily understand
is the playlist [ __ ] is the spotify [ __ ]
it's like it feels like um
almost i'm sure for a lot of artists
like an impossible task to get on some
playlists
i think i tell artists all the time man
don't focus on getting the attention of
uh industry people and playlisters focus
on one fan a day you know what i'm
saying
you focus on growing your fan base you
might have 10 fans cater to them and
grow them fans don't focus on nothing
outside of your control because all
you're going to end up getting is taken
advantage of by people who say i can
get you on this playlist yeah because if
you if you focus on the fans and you
build i mean that all that other shit's
going to come it's going to come but if
you're not they're going to see oh he
got a crazy following let me put him on
this playlist because it's going to help
us you know i mean i think that i think
i think russ is somebody who probably
initially had that perspective because
he used to just he always talks about
jeans how he used to email all the blogs
and they would never give him no [ __ ]
attention and then once he started just
focusing on
his world space he could control it
sounds so corny and cliche like i be
telling people stuff and like even like
i teach a college class and i'll be
telling people like yo what you getting
you getting what you put out you you get
what you put in like it's the creation
of the truth it's the truth
don't focus on people like yo how can i
get your attention big dog don't worry
about me get the fans up and when fans
start going crazy i'm gonna see it i'm
gonna come holla at you don't focus on
getting nobody in the music but people
do that because they think if i have you
it's gonna be easy no just do the work
focus on your fan base making or organic
fans
creating organic fan interactions
focus on growing your merch base having
people uh trained that they have to buy
stuff from you focus on uh doing shows
locally and growing your shows and
selling hard tickets training your fan
base to do that and just grow it don't
focus on getting attention no music
industry person or no playlist